True Blood star Nelsan Ellis dead at 39  ET can confirm the True Blood actor died  after complications with heart failure  he was best known for his role as the  beloved character Lafayette Reynolds on  the HBO hit show that ran from 2008 to  2014 alongside celebs quickly took to  social media to share their condolences  and mourn the loss Nelsons get on up  co-star Octavia Spencer shared a photo  of the late actor and lamented in the  caption she's heartbroken  while actress Gabrielle Union shared  that she was blown away by the tragic  news former True Blood cast mate Joe  Manganiello tweeted he is quote crushed  by his death calling him a wonderful  person and Pioneer et spoke with Nelson  in August 2016 where he revealed he was  hopeful for a Tru Blood reboot in the  future and I will be down for all day  yesterday  oh love do me  [Music]